ود ان انقل لكم باسمي وباسم اسرتي وباسم
اسره الصحفيين وباسم الشعب الفلسطيني هنا
في قطاع غزه تحياتنا واحترامنا وتقديرنا
لكل ما تفعلونه بالتاكيد غزه هذه الايام
تمر في مرحله عصيبه جدا تاريخيه جدا
استثنائيه جدا لم تمر بها في تاريخها
ولذلك الناس هنا يدفعون اثمان باهظه جدا
ويعيشون حياه كارثيه لمن لا يعرف لا يجد
الناس الاكل او الطعام
والشراب المسكن من الخيام الحمام وما
تتطلبه الحياه ليست الكريمه وانما الحياه
التي تضمن لهم الاستمراريه
مع الاسف هذا هو واقعنا فقدنا الاسره
وفقدنا الولد وفقدنا الصديق وفقدنا المكتب
وفقدنا المنزل وفقدنا الماوى ونعيش مشردين
ونعمل من خلال كل هذه الاوجاع وكل هذه
الالام وكل هذه الاثمان ومع ذلك ما زلنا
مستمرون ما زلنا مستمرون نؤكد لكم اننا
سوف نستمر في حمل هذه الرساله وفي ء هذا
[تصفيق]
الواجب